>> THOMPSON: Welcome to this week's Android
Developer Office Hours from Europe. And we
are today in Campus London our start up building
in East London. They're sleeping around about.
So, obviously we haven't had the chance to
decorate yet. But we are in the stream, yes.
And hopefully the video quality and the sound
quality is a little bit better. And we'll
try to make it look a little bit prettier
over the coming weeks. Joining as always,
Matthew Gaunt.
>> GAUNT: Hello.
>> THOMPSON: And Nick Butcher.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: You know, I think today's word
of this week would be [INDISTINCT] oh, lovely.
>> BUTCHER: In our well, lo-end vacation day.
>> THOMPSON: He's on vacation.
>> BUTCHER: Americans are [INDISTINCT].
>> THOMPSON: And well, I guess we'll get started.
Welcome to the people who've joined us in
the Hangout. I'll be looking down here quite
a lot, down here quite a lot because that's
where the [INDISTINCT]. Hey Andrew and hey
Al. Why don't you say hello, just want to
make sure that we can hear you.
>> SUTTON: Hey guys.
>> Hey.
>> THOMPSON: Hey Al.
>> GAUNT: Hey.
>> THOMPSON: Thanks for that, I can hear you.
Just bringing up the [INDISTINCT] for my little
device down here. Oh, that's where the open
[INDISTINCT] I think the other devices. So,
the big news of the day of course being, the
jolly good statues back on the lawn? That
was a big move wasn't it?
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Crazy long antennae. I need to
go and see it, and to see if they really are
that longer than the [INDISTINCT].
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: The look of that--the antennaeů
>> BUTCHER: It's got bigger reception now.
>> THOMPSON: It's cool
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: It can pickup its home signal
from wherever that is.
>> GAUNT: I remember seeing that they day
before [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Is that what I think it is?
>> BUTCHER: The event's going on. So Rich
and I we're looking up to visit Israel last
week where we met up with the locals. We developed
[INDISTINCT] there, it's very, very active
[INDISTINCT]. And so we may have to--kind
of he talked Android and the design and, you
know, [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: And then here in London this week,
Friday [INDISTINCT] in fact, there's going
to be another developer then here at Google
Campus. The--and here in London as well. I
hope we--I hope that you know about it because
tickets are sold out already. We're looking
forward to meeting up today [INDISTINCT] Android
fest this weekend.
>> GAUNT: So yeah that's theů
>> THOMPSON: DotFest.
>> GAUNT: [INDISTINCT] Slowly--something round
isn't it?
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm.
>> GAUNT: So we even got tickets for this
and we think it [INDISTINCT] and then maybe
[INDISTINCT]. They're organizers kind of [INDISTINCT]
Thank you. Yes, oh yes.
>>THOMPSON: Thus by 50 [INDISTINCT] transporting
across the world over the next few months.
We'll look out for those. Probably talk to
[INDISTINCT] and supported by Google Teams
on the ground [INDISTINCT]. What I was going
to say, the big news of course.
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> THOMPSON: It wasn't [INDISTINCT] statue
going back. The big news [INDISTINCT] us,
Android [INDISTINCT] is billion. [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER. [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] the world.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Half or three in the nation.
>> GAUNT: And I've done editing for it.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: We're announcing today, you know,
[INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Is that what the antenna was for?
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] and what? So hope
a billion activations of Android devices which
probably doesn't come much for shock because
Eric Schmidt announces it's one I'm going
to believe. [INDISTINCT] Still who wants to
join us in the Hangout? Andrew, we've got
Michael [INDISTINCT] and myself, Richard Thompson.
Does anyone from the Hangout have a question
before we'd get in to the moderator today?
>> SUTTON: Just go a quick thing today. The
guys, who are running the Dotfest in London
have released some standing remaining tickets.
So there are a few still remaining. So people
heading to London, Dotfest.com they may get
tickets if they feel like standing all day.
>> BUTCHER: Very good. In London Dotfest.com
[INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I meanů
>> SUTTON: Yeah. I'll put a link in the comments
as well.
>> BUTCHER: Perfect. Great.
>> SUTTON: Dotfest.info my mistake.
>> BUTCHER: .info?
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: Maybe that's going to make the
mic a bit hard to hear.
>> THOMPSON: All right. We were worried about
this. We didn't wire ourselves up with the
pen mics, which the studio people apparently
provided us. So, if it's too quietů
>> GAUNT: We have options.
>> THOMPSON: We do have options. So it might
get really loud now instead of being quite
quiet.
>> SUTTON: No, that's good with me.
>> THOMPSON: So you can moderate also from
our side.
>> GAUNT: I just need a hand.
>> THOMPSON: Hey Michael is that better? Is
this thing even on?
>> SUTTON: Yup we can here you.
>> THOMPSON: All right. I'll just put that
on the desk. By then every time I lean on
the desk you'll get a big knocking noise.
So you think problems neverů
>> GAUNT: No.
>> THOMPSON: We're just noisy. It must be
coming through right now as we [INDISTINCT]
microphones, we do get told to wear. And we're
like, no we don't need those. Maybe we do.
Sorry that this isn't entirely Android focus.
We should've found some Android microphones.
[INDISTINCT] Here we go. Okay, I'm on. It's
for you guys. Moderates, nothing come up in
here.
>> GAUNT: Here we go. Is that any good Michael?
>> THOMPSON: Yup. Michael says so much better,
thank you. Well thank you for mentioning it
because we have realized on the YouTube video
afterwards and have to take it down.
>> BUTCHER: And other news, new Google developers'
live video launched yesterday. So Roman Nurik
and myself start an Android design in action
shows. So, where we're focusing on how to--how
to implement Android design. And we did it
in a form of a--an app make over where we
take three of the applications which the--an
app [INDISTINCT] lookout on every Friday.
And we applied the Android design philosophy
to them to kind of like reskin and to looking
for the Android looking feel. And so hopefully
that was informative a lot of people out there
to learn what would, you know, how to apply,
add Holo kind of design language to your applications.
>> SUTTON: Okay. I actually saw it live when
you guys were doing it, it was brilliant.
I mean, you guys had the before and after
shots. So, you went through the mistakes in
the apps. And then what was good about the
redesign version. I found it really useful.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. I found that format of the
two side by side, you know, really, really
helpful too kind of. It speaks volumes, you
know, rather than reading documentationů
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> BUTCHER: ůof the App. That's what--that's
what I should do. So I hope that's ease with
you guys. And actually Roman did that the
markups last week. So he'd already [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: He always does, Roman's superman.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: So, done?
>> BUTCHER: As we said, so any live question
or should we jump into the moderator?
>> THOMPSON: Andrew liked the Android design
video as well.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, excellent.
>> THOMPSON: People shaking their heads no.
So, let's jump into the moderator, of which
I have a copy on my Nexus 7 in here. That's
what the little black window in the Hangout's
for. I need to show you things, one sec. So
here.
>> BUTCHER: Go ahead Rick the app.
>> THOMPSON: Okay. RE, this is from Phil H,
in the UK. Google Play in app purchases, I
want to be able to get the price for an in
app purchase product by the product ID when
the app starts. From the billing info page
it doesn't seem possible. Anyone know this
is possible? So Phil unfortunately we don't
have an API for retrieving the prices from
the Play Store into application. Better the
same time we recommend that you show the prices
in your applications because it reduces your
cancellation rights. So the thing that you
can do is obviously query your own server
for those prices and the Play Store accepts
the CSV input file to import pricing information.
So you can hold it all on your server and
export it as a CSV and import it into the
Play Store and your server being single price
all theů
>> BUTCHER: We could have embed that same
CSV app as an asset. And assets part of--but
it doesn't mean you're going to have to update
your information from the change of prices.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: But, yes. So we recommend the
server based approach. You can download that
same CSV file.
>> THOMPSON: But the Play Team are indeed
aware of the fact that than API is very much
desired. And although they're currently working
very hard on a developing console, they do
have a list of feedback from Google Play.
And the prices in that's definitely in it.
So sorry that's not available quite yet. Not
at all. Next up. I read that apps that define
users feature Android hardware camera in the
manifest won't be in the Nexus 7, it only
has a front facing camera. That's true. However
my photo app should work on the Nexus 7 using
camera in turn, what to do? So you can specify
requires--users features camera, and then
required equals false. And the it will pay--will
work on the Nexus 7 up here in the Play Store
and everything will go ahead and work. So
I would recommend if you want your app to
show on a Nexus 7, so that it uses the feature
camera but it's required.
>> GAUNT: Okay. So then Andrew's gone on saying,
my question relates the entry and the manifest
that Nexus 7 users can download the app devices
without Camera ET, Google TV won't have the
app show up when they search. And so yes,
in terms of basically enabling Google TV you
have to actually disable touch screen, but
that's normally a clear far way of basically
saying don't allow it on Google TV because
obviously, they're only touch screens. So
that would be covered really, I think it's
something what we've done to insure that you
really have to actually say, "I'm going to
spoke it with TV. So that should be an issue.
And, yeah, no touch screen TVs yet. Yet, one
thatů
>> BUTCHER: I was in a department store on
weekend there's a big, you know TV and they
guy was trying to touch all the iconsů
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: ůscroll all the different apps.
And maybe, you think how long until you do
that?
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: If you have kids.
>> BUTCHER: I'm not sure if you want that.
>> THOMPSON: I have hand prints all over my
TV, anyway that's how I'm used to that kind
of stuff.
>> SUTTON: ViewSonic launched yesterday a
TV which has Android on it which is a resistive
touch screen that's about 27 inches.
>>THOMPSON: How many inches?
>> SUTTON: I think it's around 27, I meanů
>> GAUNT: 27 inch resistive screen, wow.
>> SUTTON: Yeah. Let me take out the link
and I'll post it out so you guys can drool
over it.
>> GAUNT: Yeah. There are a couple of manufacturers
that are payingů
>> THOMPSON: Soů
>> BUTCHER: Wouldn't it be cool [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: I see what Andrew's saying about
the--he just post it in the chat as well.
What about other devices that don't have cameras.
I had this conversation with another partner
recently. I couldn't actually think of one.
Between us we never came up with another device
that doesn't have a camera, that's all.
>> GAUNT: I think if it happens then at the
very, very last resort you could just block
it and do the bestů
>> THOMPSON: You could blacklist it. Make
it open to everything except Google TVs.
>> SUTTON: Nexus Q?
>> THOMPSON: That's unlikely.
>> BUTCHER: Obviouslyů
>> GAUNT: I think if you canů
>> BUTCHER: It just speaks to the whole Android
approach really isn't it? You shouldn't really
think in concrete devices. You should probably
think in capabilities and users speak to us
using speeches that will define the capabilities
you require and things you don't require and
then these packets match to enable them [INDISTINCT]
send all.
>> THOMPSON: Andrew says, Nexus Q as well.
Yeah. I mean, Nexus Q.
>> GAUNT: The Nexus Q again would not have
a touch screen. So that's one way base to
know. And [INDISTINCT] else if they put USB
camera on that was supported and then what
happens?
>> THOMPSON: Right. It's a funny one.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Because the app have no functionality.
I'm looking over here because I'm just [INDISTINCT]
because the app have no functionality that
could be used--could not import photos and
use them in your application like Instagram
is still very useful without the cameras.
And I hope I answer that. Andrew is typing.
>> GAUNT: Just for you to know, we're not
looking at the cameras because we got a screen,
it's just slightly, uh, off of the camera
so whenever anyone else talks we kind of have
to look a little bit away.
>> BUTCHER: To give you the side of what we're
like.
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> THOMPSON: Well, just figuring out all [INDISTINCT]
in the studio because the chat window is for
me it's in front of us right now as we can't
actually read it and as we [INDISTINCT]. Andrew
is still typing. Okay. I'll get back to it
as soon as he's finished.
>> GAUNT: Next muffin.
>> THOMPSON: Muffin? Where does that come
from?
>> GAUNT: It's a comedian in YouTube.
>> GAUNT: Lame joke.
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT]
>> Thanks.
>> THOMPSON: I don't get it. Why would Nexus
7 not support the camera if it has a front
one? The app is pretty useless and the device
is the best camera?
>> BUTCHER: Essentially it's a legacy thing
that Android got hardware and no camera. I
think it's the biggest feature the camera
we're facing [INDISTINCT] so there's another
feature under the Android camera front facing
so you can specify it individually but if
you just use the camera urgent than that implies
real basic camera which the Nexus 7 just now.
It's in the docs [INDISTINCT] when you look
at the [INDISTINCT] users feature and stuff
but it's--perhaps not the [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: And it's documented. Yeah, it
just treats it as rear camera, unfortunately.
Okay. Anythingů
>> GAUNT: Yeah, there is one I add. I think
[INDISTINCT] in his talk this year [INDISTINCT]
so--what's his talk all about?
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. Making good apps great.
I think.
>> THOMPSON: Or I'll let you [INDISTINCT]
>> I [INDISTINCT] but it's fine, it's fine
thank you [INDISTINCT] for now.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, sorry, Andrew that is--you
understand the situation. That's exactly the
situation right now there isn't any magic
way around it I think you got the general
gist in it. So, is there any documentation
I could search for it on creating my own app
store. I'd like to have and app store of approved
only apps for use in education, health care.
>> [INDISTINCT] with Al?
>> SUTTON: Yeah, I'm sure the documentation
would be a hundreds of pages. There's nothing
definitive, there are various third party
companies who will quite happily provide branded
apps stores or if you--if one of these--a
example it's basically just a system that
can download a list of available apps. You
can check for updates and can download those
updates. I'm happy to talk about it offline
but there's a lot of wok for something that
maybe a small project.
>> BUTCHER: For those who don't know Al, that
was the [INDISTINCT] app store is [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> GAUNT:[INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Alternatively a much, much, much,
much, much, much, much easier approach would
be to launch that into the Play Store or however
you want to distribute it which is linked
back to apps in the Play Store.
>> GAUNT: Uh-hmm.
>> THOMPSON: So here's my [INDISTINCT] apps
but then.
>> BUTCHER: Yes. It is actually [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: So thenů
>> SUTTON: ůadjacent [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: [INDISTINCT] considering the feat.
>> THOMPSON: And you got a free all the update
ultimate basic functionality on the bandwidth
costs and all that already shoulder out by
us andů
>> BUTCHER: And it has the benefit of you
able to then put that app in the Play Store.
You can't list another store in the Play Store.
It's one of theů
>> THOMPSON: Yes.
>> BUTCHER: ůthe rules there isů
>> SUTTON: But that's how videos [INDISTINCT]
zone works, isn't it?
>> BUTCHER: Exactly.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, [INDISTINCT] zone is a
good example of what exactly what we're talking
about. This links straight back to us. Any
comment on that, that was actually from [INDISTINCT]
again, you should turn your microphone on
Andre, come on.
>> GAUNT: And we got another one from Andre
[INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Hold on. He's just laughing at
us now.
>> BUTCHER: All right. He's jumping [INDISTINCT]
comments [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Oh, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: And is asking if anyone knows
how you get your--how you can replace the
glass in the Nexus 7 because a friend has
dropped it on a concrete floor in two hours
applying it.
>> THOMPSON: Oh.
>> GAUNT: Ouch.
>> SUTTON: I think that's [INDISTINCT] play.google.com
in buying that one but, I don't know if anyone
can replace it. So if anyone knows, anyone
that can help try out then please jive in
the comments, but I'm not aware of, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, I don't know where you
can get to patch these things. I don't know
if calling the customers report they would
allow fixing that or paid at your expense,
I don't know.
>> BUTCHER: I think the cost, it might actually
wipe out best just to buy another one, not
just really on, he's [INDISTINCT] Galaxy Nexus
[INDISTINCT] smash screen as well [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: Yeah, wondering [INDISTINCT] while
it was raining trying to find a place you
haven't--you don't know? Yeah, that happens.
>> SUTTON: You did? Okay, did you get the
next moderator?
>> THOMPSON: This for Josh. Yes, we're all
on the Nexus 7 here. One, two, three, Nexus
7. Well.
>> SUTTON: [INDISTINCT] planning on.
>> THOMPSON: We have personalized in different
ways, I don't know why Matt defiled his with
a cloud, the thing on the back but there you
go.
>> GAUNT: It was swag that was it.
>> THOMPSON: Swag. Okay. Yeah, a little bit.
>> GAUNT: The question from Andrew Kelly again.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I know you don't come until
[INDISTINCT] release in products. We didn't
say that at the start of the show but [INDISTINCT]
more things that you don't really know except
the last one. But is there any chance that
the Android plug in for a clip would eventually
include templates and things like Action [INDISTINCT].
This would be a useful feat that would help
adoption of action bar. And else like [INDISTINCT]
so the best place to check is the Google Group,
the adt-dev Google work if you suggested there
and who knows what would happen. Yeah, unfortunately
we can't comment on that whether it's like,
whether it's not likely or anything. That's
it.
>> BUTCHER: And yes, please bear in mind is
[INDISTINCT] Google again, I'm proud to say
that we're working on a Google action bar
compatibility library. So, as when that launches
perhaps we'll see that in sometime [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: It'll be annoying if you [INDISTINCT].
Yeah. The next question is from a new person
Andrew Kelly. The one man moderator machine,
Andrew Kelly, is there a nice way to--but
they're good questions.
>> GAUNT: Yeah, I know.
>> THOMPSON: Is there a nice way to clear
the metadata [INDISTINCT] price? Oh we've
already answered this one earlier in the talk
today. There isn't a nice way. No, we don't
have a [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: The Monkey has no official API
is the official answer.
>> THOMPSON: Uh-hmm. Isn't it the only answer?
A nice way.
>> BUTCHER: I like it.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: And it says and the rest of his
question is currently scraping. Screen's scraping
in the Google Play website. I'm not doing
some boring spider like profession [INDISTINCT]
>>BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] there is a bunch of
people who reverse engineered [INDISTINCT]
that market uses in thisů
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: Very easy to use.
>> GAUNT: Used to host them, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: API but--it's not the official.
It's subject to change, it may break anytime
so, you know, at your own risk.
>> THOMPSON: And define--it's still Andrew
telling the next question. I've defined a
thing for my app and the styled things like
buttons, et cetera, but the buttons used in
my dialogue don't seem to pick up the styling,
is there specific base style that I need to
expand the dialogues?
>> BUTCHER: I can't remember offhand, probably.
>> THOMPSON: Probably.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, I think dialogues come into
their own like [INDISTINCT] spaces of the
thing. See, I always do the thing I do is
I just kind of fire up and [INDISTINCT] small
[INDISTINCT], you know like shift with the
[INDISTINCT] the platforms that [INDISTINCT]
and so [INDISTINCT] that's how I always try
to [INDISTINCT] I cannot remember off the
top of my head.
>> THOMPSON: Kelly, Andrew [INDISTINCT] because
he's misses is watching the X Factor. [INDISTINCT]
one person in X Factor what an Android [INDISTINCT]
office hours. We can talk about X Factor.
Would that be more intriguing [INDISTINCT]
population. I need to watch it butů
>> BUTCHER: Actually no, more intriguing than
Android then.
>> THOMPSON: You're right. See half billion
devices activated. So back at the top of the--which
we ask is there any questions from inside
to Hangout yet? Because we are munching through
the moderator.
>> BUTCHER: There's a couple coming on the
[INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Let's go for that one.
>> BUTCHER: So Josh, he was asking for using
Nexus 7's [INDISTINCT] in he wants to buy
a Nexus 7. He's a [INDISTINCT] developer [INDISTINCT]
schools, studying all day. And he wants to
use it for testing and finding out. Yeah,
there's no question but I recommend it. It's
a good device, it's a Nexus device, without
[INDISTINCT] in between you and Google so
its kind of going to get awesome updates and
so on and so as the developer, you can do
a lot of works and this was on pretty reasonable
price so I highly recommended it. I love mine.
Any more questions?
>> GAUNT: There's another on the bottom of
the [INDISTINCT] actually [INDISTINCT] service
to get updates from a server. Updates are
not scheduled, it's random. Thank you.
>> BUTCHER: Sounds to me like a perfect case
of push messaging using GCM, Google Cloud
Messaging.
>> THOMPSON: That's what I do.
>> BUTCHER: So that just requires to have
some kind of server infrastructure of your
own. So you have to use your server infrastructure
to ping our push servers which will then send
a [INDISTINCT] to the device. So, that is
one requirements you could set up that [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: For example to do that if that's
not possible then yes you could use the [INDISTINCT]
manager to schedule to wake up and start a
service to grab and check for a place essentially
but my gut feeling is to try to get a push
for this kind of non scheduled thing because
you'll be much more [INDISTINCT] and also
updates would come through faster, you know,
just try [INDISTINCT] push down the device
of the [INDISTINCT] and have some period of
delay.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, please, don't make a polling
service at least that would be pretty hard
in this, I guessů
>> BUTCHER: And if you do you use the inexact
for [INDISTINCT] that's the Android [INDISTINCT]
to try lining all up so you're not waking
up the device the whole time.
>> THOMPSON: That'll be bad if you don't do
that then you can start occurring battery
[INDISTINCT] and battery hog. And people will
uninstall your app and boo. We're in public.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: That's just boo. What is from--for
us the recommended way to control super light
database connection in a multi threaded environment?
Is having warnings system database help us
share between threads is a good idea and does
using a content provider help? Yes, using
a content provider is the recommended way
to control a super light database generally
inside Android. Yeah, you know, it's just
going to provide the functionality and synchronization
that you need. Without you having to code
it at all yourself. I would personally go
for content writer in the situation. I know
other devs have gone for single terms and,
you knowů
>> GAUNT: Uh-hmm.
>> THOMPSON: ůtrying to synchronize it themselves
and things that--passing [INDISTINCT] around.
But I mean ContentProvider is the thing that
Android provides to do it. So unless you're
pretty confident about coding it up yourself,
you might as well check the ContentProvider.
There's a lot of good sample code for ContentProviders
out there.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. The less kind of multi [INDISTINCT]
synchronization code you write yourself the
better. Just for the [INDISTINCT] in it makes
us.
>> THOMPSON: Indeed. I'm just scrolling down
to the [INDISTINCT] again.
>> BUTCHER: So, it where in the [INDISTINCT]
is there a way to get a list of counts with
out going through the AccountManager to actually
by the ContactsContracts.setting will always
returns zero with anything by [INDISTINCT].
>> SUTTON: Oh, I'm [INDISTINCT]ContactsContracts.setting
I'm not quiet sure what it is because I've
always just used the AccountManager to get
list of the accounts and device.
>> THOMPSON: Me too.
>> BUTCHER: And then why would youů
>> THOMPSON: I mean, definitelyů
>> BUTCHER: ůwant to void that? Are you trying
to not have to ask for the permission, I guess?
>> THOMPSON: But then you're still doing the
thing with permission. Why would you try and
get around the permission and then just go.
>> BUTCHER: It makes me feel likeů
>> THOMPSON: Sounds sneaky.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. We feel like the AccountManager
is the right way to do this.
>> GAUNT: Yeah. In ContactsContracts. Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Hey, it's possible about settings
returning zero because you don't have the
AccountManager's permission as well. Other
things outside ofů
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm. Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: It might be using the AccountManager
to get those things. You should just check
in the API docs if it says it requires those
permissions. It would be strange if we did
have a way of getting around the AccountManager
permission and we'd probably try and close
it if there was a way.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. I would say. It's never
been.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: Security issue.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. Okay. In which case we
are--can we refresh this? Sometimes they're
coming during the--during the a couple of
minutes away.
>> BUTCHER: There's a question in Google+
stream again.
>> GAUNT: Yup.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] up byů
>> THOMPSON: Aviva.
>> BUTCHER: Aviva.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: Best way toů
>> THOMPSON: Hi, Aviva.
>> BUTCHER: ůdraw charts on Android. And
anyone got the--you recommended the charting
libraries?
>> THOMPSON: I don't know.
>> BUTCHER: Is a [INDISTINCT] which I know
before.
>> THOMPSON: I drew my own once.
>> BUTCHER: Did you?
>> THOMPSON: Some pixels and lines and stuff.
>> GAUNT: I did mineů
>> THOMPSON: It's on a canvas.
>> GAUNT: ůas well.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: It could be a canvas.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: That wasů
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> GAUNT: I ended up with just trying to make
a wrong chart which was just highly generic
and just try to stick to a bit and adapt the
patterns, so I wasn't constantly going in
adding in pixels left, front and center. And
it's not too bad to do on your own. It may
be nice if there was just [INDISTINCT] directly
but I can't say I found any. I don't think
some people might be changing this one.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I didn't try anything.
Which one did I use? Any past on [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] she did a graph
but then I can't remember.
>> BUTCHER: And it's kind ofů
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] I was truly at home.
>> BUTCHER: I know.
>> THOMPSON: You eventually Android you are
keep on reviewing.
>> BUTCHER: Fix out, it's brings out some
interior interesting ones a Chartdroid Android
plots and H [INDISTINCT] engine.
>> THOMPSON: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: So I can't recommend them by myself.
Is there anyone live can comment on their
experience using this [INDISTINCT] engines,
then that's fine. There was an interesting
on I remember seeing [INDISTINCT] open source
[INDISTINCT]. And we have a [INDISTINCT] package
thing. They open sourced that up. And that
had some pretty roughs in it. I--well, it
might be worth checking up. I don't know what
it is, but a little attractive.
>> No.
>> THOMPSON: You know, Track is always better.
>> BUTCHER: I think so.
>> GAUNT: Uh-hmm.
>> THOMPSON: At least try it for attractive.
Obviously that way.
>> BUTCHER: What?
>> THOMPSON: So, someone else has joined us
in the Hangout. Scott, hey Scott Howell. Do
you have any questions for us today in the
Hangout?
>> HOWELL: No. Just listening in, thank you
though.
>> THOMPSON: Thanks for joining. Looks like
you got quite a tech desk set up over there.
>> HOWELL: That's not what my wife calls it.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I've got it. So next fun.
It's not a proper game.
>> BUTCHER: So, where are you joining us from,
Scott?
>> HOWELL: I'm sorry, say again?
>> BUTCHER: Where are you joining us from?
>> HOWELL: South Florida.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, lovely.
>> THOMPSON: How nice. What time is it? Jeez.
8:00, 6:00--no it's not.
>> HOWELL: It's 9:30 AM.
>> THOMPSON: It's not so bad.
>> BUTCHER: Not far from here.
>> THOMPSON: Excellent. Well, welcome here.
If you do have any questions, feel free to
jump in because we're out.
>> HOWELL: It's nice to be [INDISTINCT] stuck
up for your link.
>> THOMPSON: To every chance in library [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: Yeah. And there's tons
>> BUTCHER: And let's put in.
>> GAUNT: Yeah. Android charts, graphs, diagrams,
perhaps putting a draw thing. This is the
one I'm stuck up in replacing, so we can go
and--yeah, you'll be set like go off from
packages. Yeah, tons.
>> THOMPSON: I guess Aviva was actually looking
for a recommendation from us, then he's found
out and got all--there's hundreds of these
things, which one should I use?
>> GAUNT: Or at least like--it's not the main
top answers listed down to three. Which is
Chartdroid, Android [INDISTINCT] HR and then
[INDISTINCT] and soů
>> SUTTON: Some of the others have a commercial
license as well. So it's a--Google it out.
>> THOMPSON: How dare they try to make money.
>> SUTTON: The most expenses of all those
is over $300, so.
>> THOMPSON: Wow.
>> BUTCHER: I was like one of my own choice
comes to be with the Canvas.
>> GAUNT: Yeah. Can't get wrong.
>> THOMPSON: I have a contacts and I think
that's when I click that [INDISTINCT], oh,
is that one of my own.
>> SUTTON: There's nothing like a chunk of
Canvas because [INDISTINCT] later.
>> THOMPSON: Nothing like a chunk of Canvas.
Well, since youů
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]. So why [INDISTINCT]
ask why Android doesn't have a multiple users
and so anyone who plays Android--well, realize
that there's some [INDISTINCT] of that coming
already open source than Jelly Bean. So watch
this space to see another gets exposed.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I've seen people from Android
use a [INDISTINCT] typing commands into terminals
that Android devices and magic things happening,
so. So we must, what?
>> BUTCHER: And the next up. Mortz, it's very
funny [INDISTINCT] again asked, is it possible
to buy cards into Google now would know as
an app verifier.
>> THOMPSON: Oh.
>> BUTCHER: So, no. Unfortunately, there is
no develop rate going and [INDISTINCT] as
is. Who knows, maybe in the future hands but
right now, nope.
>> THOMPSON: Nope.
>> BUTCHER: That's right.
>> THOMPSON: An interesting one.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, that would be fun. Interesting
to have what kind of we've mentioned you'd
like to surface in there.
>> GAUNT: Yeah. If weů
>> THOMPSON: If only we could just override--have
a different weather card to a different source,
maybe there [INDISTINCT] will go pretty well.
>> BUTCHER: And some of theů
>> THOMPSON: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: ůactions you can form from the
cards to just pile off intense plus you can,
you know, divide alternative, you knowů
>> THOMPSON: You have a stock ticker on that
maybe?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, I do.
>> THOMPSON: You just went [INDISTINCT] action
to that. I take care of the [INDISTINCT] here.
Oh, that reminds me, I still have to reply
which notification andů
>> BUTCHER: Chronometer.
>> THOMPSON: ůChronometer. I also might start
with try to get some feed on the app would
be on Friday.
>> BUTCHER: Yes, it would be.
>> THOMPSON: My mission right now. Because
I don't want to do some live [INDISTINCT]
again. Fairly, it's quite easy. On my own
force, just have to set the Chronometer which
notification [INDISTINCT] which you can kill
it again.
>> SUTTON: Do you want let the guys know what
app review it's going to be Rich?
>> THOMPSON: No. Well, thank you for submitting
it, Al.
>> SUTTON: Oh, it's my pleasure.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, Al will pay for it.
>> THOMPSON: Al will pay for it, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: I didn't know that.
>> THOMPSON: Soů
>> BUTCHER: Good choice to that teaching out.
>> THOMPSON: ůthe American side about team
reviewing timer and countdown apps on Friday
and Al knows that I've made one about 50,000
years ago. My first star Android. So we put
it up for review. So my team's going to rip
me apart or a new one or some place on Friday
which is nice.
>> BUTCHER: Well, making of that [INDISTINCT]
how awesome it is.
>> THOMPSON: They might. And if they do, it
will all be down to Marie's [INDISTINCT] much
better designs than mine.
>> THOMPSON: Even though I apparently I didn't
implement them properly. We still tried to
distance ourselves somewhat from the app.
I kind of like my designs.
>> BUTCHER: So I think [INDISTINCT].
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. You don't need a few page,
the machine countdown and so much.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: I'll do that as well. Open a
few page and you'll then open the--you play
didn't exist back then. Swiping didn't exist
gestures. They were voice [INDISTINCT]. Okay.
Why we're kind of filling in time here because
we've got half an hour to go.
>> KELLY: [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Only one participant, let's jump
on him quick.
>> BUTCHER: No. The other one.
>> THOMPSON: It says his name is Zabi. He's
got picture, doesn't have a video. Doesn't
have a video, maybe he has a microphone. Hey
Zabi, do you have a question for us?
>> Okay. I'm sorry. [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Have you exhausted him?
>> THOMPSON: Remind you if it wasn't for Android
Kelly, this Hangout would have been four minutes.
But fortunately [INDISTINCT] got all the questions
ever. I think you want [INDISTINCT]. And it's
also the--it's the other question. He asked
for some question for you. Seven people interested
in aů
>> BUTCHER: I knew we pick on the live participants
say a couple of years you said that you changed
into the Android design action session yesterday?
Any feedback? Anything you like to--you want
to see more of, you've spent too long or very
useful? Anything, that when we used for that?
>> SUTTON: One other that could be cool would
be, if you could get the developers to join
in as well and say whether there's something
thinking behind the designs or how sort of
that, like to implement them because it's
quite closing the design changes but hearing
about how they try to implement as well that'd
be useful.
>> GAUNT: I think there's something they knew,
the guys in the US do there. I think they
had a couple of [INDISTINCT] so they actually
have the guys suite develop their on the Hangout
live and it--yeah, you're right, it does add
another level of kind of understanding and
I know you said they got tips and tricks and
quite ready to learn.
>> SUTTON: I understand Nick, you're limited
to about a half an hour, so I--what you can
do is really limit it and it's kind of a weighing
out between minutes, we've getting more app
redesigns or whether it's worth fixing on
a few, then.
>> BUTCHER: Well, since [INDISTINCT] yeah,
you know you can make it longer if you think
a longer format would be--would work and we
could make it an hour or less. It's quite
lot of work to the app redesign as it try
to turn around three days a week that it takes--it
takes probably lots of time. And over [INDISTINCT]
is what [INDISTINCT] straight up. So the good
thing about the best buying into the a bit
more of a general show as well as to having
more--talking about more in the news, so we
spent a little bit talking abut the Holo Colors
Generator which actually generate the themes,
the buttons and the next more files.
>> THOMPSON: True.
>> BUTCHER: To personalize a few things who
did more of that kind of news and maybe--I
don't know. Talking about what's going on
in the community, not just being the app,
app redesign. So [INDISTINCT] best way out
a little bit with out, you know, spending
full time job redesigning apps.
>> SUTTON: That'll be quite cool. Hasn't [INDISTINCT]
produce a video this week in Android or something
like that? That wasů
>> THOMPSON: He did five minutes work on what's
coming up this week which we're halfway through
now.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: That was a--that was also pretty
useful because there's some other things that
were going on that I wasn't aware of, so.
>> THOMPSON: We've got some upcoming other
ways on discovering our videos scene as well
and keeping up to date with everything that's
going on this pretty much not constant TV
channel. If you go to developers.google.com
like and cross all our products. The calendar
is almost full. Soon there'll be more than
one show onů
>> BUTCHER: Wednesday [INDISTINCT] day.
>> THOMPSON: Wednesday straight through the
whole day you can watch something from the
Google Team live on YouTube live.
>> BUTCHER: And don't worry as soon you guys
tune into multiple office hours sections,
do tune in to the US one as well.
>> SUTTON: I've pick up the Asia Pacific one
before an [INDISTINCT] it's only 7:00 in the
morning. I watched it during breakfast because
that's how sad I am, really.
>> THOMPSON: No, no, I've watched that as
well. They've done a slightly a different
format. They do less questions and they're
doing a bit more news about the week and then
they do a technical part as well. So, here's
worth watching that and what do you think
of that Al?
>> SUTTON: I quite like it. I like the technical
presentation of the start. It will be interesting
to see how many different topics they can
gather and whether they go into depth so whether
they keep stuff quite light. But I think it--what
seems to work quite well and it means that
they didn't end up with half an hour to fill
up the Android or anything like that so.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT].
>> THOMPSON: All right. So, yeah.
>> GAUNT: We've got some more questions.
>> BUTCHER: Questions, questions, questions
going on the [INDISTINCT] here they are.
>> GAUNT: Yes, so David Scott. When in not
[INDISTINCT] is there way to pass some kind
of string like to develop a payload that will
show up on Google checkout/payout [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: No, so all right.
>> GAUNT: That's quite similar to the other
questions we're using it, trying to find out
the price system. Maybe, maybe not, yeah.
No. Moving on. It's from Chris over here.
And why is HTML5/CSS3 so outrageously bad
on Android--Android devices in general even
in countries [INDISTINCT] one called devices
the HTML5 experience is really slow. The page
requires [INDISTINCT] especially with [INDISTINCT]
shouldn't it not get more attention? I think
I'm interested to know with your phone to
like the embeddable web view or whether your
referring to actual Google Chrome because
those are very different. So yeah, Chrome
Team they kind of [INDISTINCT] on the HTML5
spec and noticeable thing speed et cetera.
>> BUTCHER: And they [INDISTINCT] yet.
>> THOMPSON: If you're working [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: What's going on?
>> THOMPSON: Oh, it's Andrew's mic, sorry.
I'm going to meet you Andrew. I unless you
want to, you know, you want to say something
before you get muted? No?
>> KELLY: No, that's all right.
>> BUTCHER: Denied.
>> THOMPSON: Sorry, you've been muted. Much
as the X Factor I think we can just listen
to five seconds of anything with out having
copyright issues.
>> SUTTON: Hoping back to the HTML5 thing
is probably also worth thinking about the
processing power of mobile devices. A lot
of websites I've seenů
>> THOMPSON: Yes.
>> SUTTON: ůand they started getting into
really complex stuff already designed for
desktops. So trying to run them on a mobile
processor is just painful. It's [INDISTINCT]
to trying to run Flash on a mobile processor.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I'll ask you in a point
even core level devices you compare that quad
core desktop that performances deference's
still matter.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah. And it's layers, layers,
upon layers, upon layers of abstraction [INDISTINCT]
when you have these resources trained devices
that closer you get like down the stack the
more performance you're going to get as you
add more lays like a web layer on top and
that's something [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yes, benefits the web jail something.
>> BUTCHER: I think we've seen the trend of
big developers moving away from a lot like
Facebook into myself as well with, what's
the best comments today and that's all [INDISTINCT]
and make it as a wonder listů
>> THOMPSON: They got away from HTML.
>> BUTCHER: They were titanium andů
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: ůthey've gone native now andů
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. That was [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: For much better performance still
looks like [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Do they say we've launched already
or is it sneaky? Did they say they launched
already?
>> BUTCHER: Yes.
>> THOMPSON: Does it have a Google task I'm
thinking.
>> BUTCHER: I haven't checked that.
>> THOMPSON: I shall check it. Okay. [INDISTINCT]
whether that app does look iOSed or not.
>> SUTTON: It was quite interesting that yesterday
at the Tech crunch conference from [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: ůactually said the--they're moving
towards HTML5 was probably one of the worst
mistakes his made on mobile so.
>> THOMPSON: So we've wasted two years of
everyone's time or something.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Like the HTML5. Pretty interesting
thing [INDISTINCT] which is natural comes
out. Does it like and how fast and super snappy
it is like they've already put a lot of effort
in making amazing there with a lot of anticipation.
>> BUTCHER: But the Android doesn't really
requiresů
>> THOMPSON: Oh, I putů
>> BUTCHER: It's grand [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: We build with Android apps.
>> SUTTON: And they're still hiring more people
as well so they're building and building that
team.
>> THOMPSON: Talking about how many people.
So, advertising is not here, yeah, our time--our
team--a time. Our team is currently looking
for one new member to sit here in the London
office. So if you're into Android and you
can see developer advocacy of Android. Get
in touch on me on Google+. I'm really looking
for someone with some European language skills
but, there you go. Get in touch with me on
Google+ and we can have a talk about it. Okay.
Our team we can fill the spot soon before
we [INDISTINCT] headcount comes and go like
anything in Google.
>> BUTCHER: And what went pretty well, I thought
[INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: There's another one from David Scott.
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
>> GAUNT: So, this was still the Google Play
getting a payload in the report. What would
you--what would you suggest the best solution
for an app with the--with possibly 40,000
separate in app payments with hundreds added
monthly.
>> THOMPSON: What would you suggest the best
solution for an app with 40,000 separate [INDISTINCT]
payments?
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] we work on a magazine
appů
>> THOMPSON: What?
>> BUTCHER: ů[INDISTINCT] application which
we can download more for magazines and issues
there off [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Okay. Well, definitely the [INDISTINCT]
who knows if anyone tested the CSV import
and export with 40,000 items in it but that's
going to way to go, that'sů
>> BUTCHER: No, I think your trying to look
out sales of individual and stuff.
>> THOMPSON: Well, I have to design the app
orů
>> BUTCHER: No, no, we're working on it.
>> GAUNT: Basically you take the CSV filesů
>> THOMPSON: Oh.
>> GAUNT: ůwith it, it will be more useful
to than to use our [INDISTINCT] I imagine.
I have no idea
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] we'll pass it to
the team who built it.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I don't know what--in the
sales report what comes out if you end up
anyway. Since the [INDISTINCT] one separate,
they must be separate. Surelyů
>> GAUNT: There's a way you can split it and
just pronounce andů
>> THOMPSON: On the sales report hopefully
you'll see what items are purchased. I don't
have an app within app billing in it. It's
like people [INDISTINCT]. Is there anyone
on the Hangout have an in app billing app
currently live in the Play Store? No, no.
Interesting.
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
>> GAUNT: That's the place.
>> THOMPSON: You'll understand there because
I'm just typing again this being quite a few
things going to the chat. Scott said GameSalad
and Andrew says he's working on one. I don't
know why GameSalad came up. Did miss something?
>> BUTCHER: No, [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: GameSalad.
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> THOMPSON: App building up. It's got starting
a new code.
>> GAUNT: That's not like the old [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: What? A Titanium or what?
>> GAUNT: Now, the Android developers [INDISTINCT]
thing the drag-and-drop.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah. I thought it went up to
MIT?
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Android app [INDISTINCT].
>> SUTTON: That [INDISTINCT] GameSalad seems
to be a cross platform application for generating
apps.
>> THOMPSON: Oh he then says now I got your
attention. How about--how about integrating
voice over IP vehicles. Voice Over IP vehicles
with Hangouts as my Android so if you want
to.
>> GAUNT: Go in.
>> THOMPSON: Invite people with [INDISTINCT]
Google+ Hangouts maybe.
>> BUTCHER: Is there an intent starting to
Hangout?
>> GAUNT: That would be very cool.
>> THOMPSON: How about it. Voice Over IP video
calls with Hangouts via Android integrating
into.
>> BUTCHER: It took him out like I just kicking
off the--let's say Hangout so it's just [INDISTINCT]
off to Google+ to start it or are you talking
about having it run in our infrastructure
and then give you a stream [INDISTINCT] video
shows in your app by playing a game and typing
audio and video or whatever just come out.
>> HOWELL: It just--it just seemed that it's
a similar technology and you know we've had--we've
had the discussions on it on how to take--say
we've got a video a VoIP called platform how
to enjoy the versatility of Hangouts within
that, you know, or vice versa. Making a call
if you will by way of the Google Hangout to
somebody.
>> Okay. I think [INDISTINCT] with something.
>> I think it's probably [INDISTINCT]
>> Sort of that. We just dropped out and then
mainů
>> I think what'sů
>> We'll up here as soon as be coming back
in a second.
>> I think [INDISTINCT] after. Are you talking
about conferences people and directly into
a Hangout so basically you'll be able to select
the group of people what you want to join
to Hangout and they get invited in.
>> HOWELL: Essentially, you know, sure, yeah,
because one--at one level absolutely.
>> So we missed quite about a bit unfortunately
due to the drop out sorry.
>> So, I'm still some what confuse. You're
trying to get VoIP trying to [INDISTINCT]
connect to Hangout would you just that you
mean use Hangouts within [INDISTINCT]
>> HOWELL: And then now suggested now even
creating a conference from within a Hangout
to back out to a video call VoIP. The technology
seems similar if you just be interesting to
enjoy the use of both directions.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> HOWELL: We'll hang out from [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: ůand the Hangouts that are doing
[INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: And they set any, you know, we'll
talk about the Hangouts API and what you can't
do in that, I don't know about, you know,
connections to other, you know, video, audio
streams and [INDISTINCT] there advice and
that's about it.
>> GAUNT: Yeah, I think very interesting to
know whether you could access through Hangout
API [INDISTINCT].
>> THOMPSON: Well, I don't think we can [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: But it's Google+ [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Okay. Listen one more quick run
through the letter [INDISTINCT] and the comments
just in case anything is coming. And I think
we have seven questions, next one is the comments,
right, nothing new coming in? I think about
several questions next one from the comments,
right, nothing new come in?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, [INDISTINCT] come in and
said back to the links to charting libraries.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: And he's wondering if there's
a standard implementation. So I don't think
there is one. One thing that I can think off
is the factory stuff. Not like [INDISTINCT]
to sharing moment this is WiFi and stuff [INDISTINCT]
it's the same but it might be worth and technically
a source code for that.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, that quite pretty got impressed,
yes.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] in the third part
there is [INDISTINCT] I would think that's
the reason.
>> GAUNT: Plus they don't do what you do.
Tweak them, change them, fix them up, add
stuff, and then re[INDISTINCT] back to the
community, always another plus.
>> BUTCHER: So Phil [INDISTINCT] asking if
the--and the building blocks section of the
design side which goes through all the different
controls, you can go to any application and
when it's going to get and examples and create
at some point. So I guess in front of, I mean
like visual examples [INDISTINCT] I think
it has already has a most of about code examples.
If it s a latter, I'm going to ahead and say
maybe not, okay this design side is very much
prestigious that. I would say if you feel
that the [INDISTINCT] documentation side,
so I will just [INDISTINCT] the code like
you will be and [INDISTINCT] or but the documentation
on. In the reference section or even the Android
training pages. If you feel that they're not,
you know, upstart of interesting maybe could
do a better job of joining them up. You know,
linking through from the side of the building
block page to and we start to implement it.
Then that could worth looking at.
>> SUTTON: And the documentation, the design
documentation. So partly Android open source
project. So people can actually submit there
changes if they want to, so located in the
frameworks based docs package. So if anyone
wants to make fixes, they can fix it so much
[INDISTINCT] and become a famous author of
the design documents.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm. As you [INDISTINCT]. Yes,
I thought [INDISTINCT] you mean are the good
examples. Yes, I think the desire is to keep
the design section down to design. So it's
not stir up designers with the code. And but
yes certainly linking [INDISTINCT] tips for
implantation is interesting will be up and
turning.
>> GAUNT: I think it's nice to see that Android
has got to the point where the designers is
so important compared to back in the day when
we didn't have such kind of strict standards
so. I think keeping the two separate it's
kind of made a lot of sense. But yeah, maybe
it's the case that needs to be here. A couple
of strings down together.
>> BUTCHER: Lastly, I already like the redesign
again for [INDISTINCT] separated it out. But
maybe we do need to just think for your ads
and watch the process.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: The dispute ones has got some
great information on publishing and getting
your [INDISTINCT] together. I think quite
a lot of people [INDISTINCT] originally I
just put everyone in the design page but now
you distribute links as well.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> THOMPSON: As it become more familiar, you
know, a different [INDISTINCT] inside that.
>> BUTCHER: That's what the device in our
generation [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> THOMPSON: Device Art Generator. Steven
[INDISTINCT] just joins us in the chat and
in the Hangout. I just wonder if he's got
any questions before we sign off today.
>> BUTCHER: And [INDISTINCT] that they're
[INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: And what do I [INDISTINCT] I
saw that as well, never mind maybe [INDISTINCT]
where I locked it..
>> BUTCHER: If [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: I didn't, yeah. I think--didn't
Sparky say that he'd get to the point where
he'd lock it a bit before. So then people
couldn't [INDISTINCT]
>> He did.
>> GAUNT: I think, you meanů
>> THOMPSON: He said get your questions in
early next week because I'm going to lock
it before the event.
>> BUTCHER: Is there were all coming in during
that last week?
>> THOMPSON: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: That's fine.
>> THOMPSON: I don't know unlock it again.
The Sparky has the power. Next week I prefer
the questions coming in during the [INDISTINCT].
So next week we won't lock it.
>> SUTTON: I have a feelingů
>> It's [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: ůThat it on an--on an [INDISTINCT]
trigger because he's already got there one
for next the office--oh, the moderator for
next week open it. It says come back at 6:00
to submit your questions.
>> Okay.
>> GAUNT: Also we actually got sort of the
time right just, yeah, the time where we [INDISTINCT]
any questions.
>> SUTTON: And is it worthů
>>THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] are you.
>> SUTTON: I'm just wondering whatů
>> THOMPSON: What was his question?
>> SUTTON: Sorry.
>> THOMPSON: Does anyone know whether the
Android at proximity alert on the location
manager is battery intensive? Is the at proximity
alert on location manager battery intensive?
No, no, no.
>> BUTCHER: And this is the area of [INDISTINCT]
that's his stuff [INDISTINCT] location?
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, itů
>> GAUNT: A space to [INDISTINCT] a very long
time about this. They said that even the GPS
icon is there. He said that it's actually
designed to be quite efficient in terms of
not actually GPS chip into it, actually needs
to. He told me to look in the source code
to see if I can then stop it from doing that.
And then essentially brought my own version
of it. When I was looking into it awhile ago,
about the same time, I think some people have
commented that it may not be the case. So
I'd say, I'd stick with [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: The [INDISTINCT] is here. Yes,
this will definitely eat your battery.
>> GAUNT: Okay. So ignore what I said.
>> THOMPSON: You never want to be setting
on a couple of Approximity [INDISTINCT] in
any case. To your case you describe isn't
really catered for proximity or not. The best
you want to add about 20, sometimes 80 alerts
with no time expiration with the radius around
500 meters, okay. A better alternative would
be to use an alarm and service to check your
current location against your center location
this will let you manage the location services
you want to use GPS or some ID as well as
the frequency of checks. Doing it this way
will let you manage your battery much more
effectively. So, yeah [INDISTINCT] the man
on batteries andů
>> BUTCHER: His battery.
>> THOMPSON: His battery pals.
>> THOMPSON: That way [INDISTINCT] if you
are then you can get it back. Hey, Steven,
you got our question next?
>> Yeah, I have a question regarding with
locks.
>> THOMPSON: Okay.
>> Can you understand me?
>> I have and service which runs in the back
from which connects to location data and through
some [INDISTINCT] hello? Necessary to which
is wake lock when screen is off.
>> THOMPSON: Sorry [INDISTINCT] we lost you
through the half of that question.
>> Okay.
>> THOMPSON: You're dropping in anů
>> So I have an--I have a series which is
registering in wake lock and as collect location
data. Always when this [INDISTINCT] and do
you need--do we need an wake lock for this
when screen is off to get enough computation
power to do some filtering of GPS position
and so on or is it just sufficient to do it
without the wake lock?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, you only get--was it ten
seconds [INDISTINCT] yeah.
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, you will get pause very
quickly afterwards. So it's [INDISTINCT] I
don't how long your computations are going
t take. But it is more than a second or two
then you have to definitely wait for wake
lock.
>> Okay. It's good choice to read--okay.
>>THOMPSON: Yeah, just take the wake lock
and then turn it back off again, drop it as
soon as you can.
>>GAUNT: We have another question on theů
>> THOMPSON: Yes, he's turned up. Hey [INDISTINCT]
finally you tell it right at the end of it.
He's got his [INDISTINCT] as well. So we couldn't
be in Israel within this week. I'm sure your
weather is better than ours. Apparently we
got another question coming through.
>> GAUNT: Yeah, from Benjamin Wise.
>> THOMPSON: Oh, hi Ben.
>> GAUNT: Benů
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: I show it to Ben and maybe prepare
they took care of the [INDISTINCT] last week
and [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] then.
>> GAUNT: [INDISTINCT] to do here, so. Thanks
guys [INDISTINCT] and yeah, Ben says all the
intention on supporting [INDISTINCT] as in
[INDISTINCT] for Android application and I
don't know what [INDISTINCT] is.
>> THOMPSON: And we can't talk about [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: No. Al you might be a bit more
than [INDISTINCT] some talk on the on new
[INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Yeah, that's right and basically
they've decided to take a step back and start
from scratch from the Android building system
to see what's happening. Great list one of
the systems that was in there as a potential
for support. It seems to be less favored because
it's not a mainstream system by mainstream.
I just mean it's got a critical mass of uses.
I'm sure there are a lot of people who really
like it. I can't see it from what's being
said at the moment being supported in the
first part of the new build system but there's
nothing to say that it wouldn't have support
for a build later because it there are quite
a few people who are interested in seeing
it. If Benjamin's really interested, ADT-Dev
is the group on Google groups. Jump in and
that's see if it can be that it's what you
need and see if the guys are willing to put
in the effort to produce what you want.
>> BUTCHER: Okay. That was [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Cool. Thanks.
>> THOMPSON: All right. Well now [INDISTINCT]
it's time to go [INDISTINCT] he can take over.
Thanks all for joining us again today for
our first Hangout from the new studio in Campus
London. Hopefully we'll get to introduce some
of the locals start ups around here on sometimes
soon as well [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Yeah [INDISTINCT] get back to
London [INDISTINCT]
>> THOMPSON: Yeah, that will be in this building
too. Other than that, thanks very much.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, until next week keep [INDISTINCT]
questions into the moderator for next week
and [INDISTINCT] the Androids [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Thanks guys.
>> THOMPSON: [INDISTINCT] cheers everyone.
Unstoppable.
>> GAUNT: And elegant.